[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALLAN NAIM: I'm Allan Naim.
I work on Google
Kubernetes Engine
at Google-- part of our product
management organization.
And I'm joined here
by Rohit Agarwalla.
ROHIT AGARWALLA: Hi, everyone.
It's a privilege to be
speaking here at Next
and talking to everybody here.
Like Allan mentioned, I am a
principal engineer at Cisco
and the overall architect for
the Cisco and Google solution.
And as Allan goes through the
first part of the section,
I'll go into more
details and, as well,
give you a nice overview of the
demo as part of the solution.
ALLAN NAIM: Yeah.
So let's talk about what we're
going to cover in the session.
So by the end of
the session, we'd
like you to walk
away with really
an understanding
around, what are the use
cases that the Google-Cisco
hybrid cloud offering actually
unlocks?
Walks.
And then what are the
components that make up
all these various use cases?
So we're going to
really focus on working
through the stack and all
the various components
that make up the stack, talk
about the different use cases,
and then Rohit is actually going
to show you a super cool demo.
It's actually a
very exciting demo
that leverages all these various
technologies together and shows
you the power of it.
So before I get started,
just show of hands,
how many developers
here in this audience?
OK.
How about IT admins?
Business folks?
Cool.
Anyone here running
containers in production?
OK.
What about Kubernetes
in production?
Nice.
Anybody running Google
Kubernetes Engine?
Right on.
Great.
So let's get started.
When you look at the
overall cloud evolution,
we've gone through these
phases every 10 years.
And we are currently somewhere
between the red and blue dot,
in terms of evolution taking
place today that's really
been driven by transformation
that containers have really
brought to the market.
For a long time, the
only path forward
was really from an
infrastructure as a service
perspective, a lift
and shift to the cloud,
and then modernized
in the cloud.
And we've really
been looking at ways,
in terms of bringing all the
various goodness of the cloud,
to you wherever you're running
your application so that you
can modernize where
you are and move
to the cloud at your own pace.
So this trend that
we're seeing right now
around cloud-native
services is really something
that the market
is picking up on.
And I have to say, in my entire
career in the IT industry,
I haven't seen
this much traction
as I'm seeing right now.
This whole notion of being
able to build services that
can literally run anywhere
and being able to manage them
from a central location, I
think, is key to this trend
that we're seeing right now
around cloud native services.
And then Hybrid has really
become an enterprise reality.
I'm sure a lot of
you have applications
that probably fall into any
one of these categories here.
For a very long
time, the only path
was really to go from
on-prem to public cloud.
And that's a great path.
But as Diane alluded to
in the keynote, only 10%
of applications
today have really
migrated to the public cloud.
There's a reason for that.
Running and migrating
applications
from on-prem to the
public cloud is hard.
Many organizations are
looking at figuring out
how to take a monolith, break
it up into microservices,
figure out where to run
these microservices--
do you run them on-prem?
Do you run them in the cloud?
How do you connect
these services together?
Some of you probably
have portfolios
of thousands of applications.
Each application has
different characteristics
and data privacy requirements.
Some have to stay on-prem.
Some can easily
move to the cloud.
How do you figure all that out?
But the key here is, how do
you manage that portfolio
of application in such a
way where you're doing it
consistently without having
to use this tool for on-prem,
this tool for cloud, this
tool for microservices,
a different tool for
policy management,
a different tool for security?
Those are really hard problems.
Our goal here really is
to bridge these two worlds
together.
So on one hand, you have
the modernization evolution
that's happening from
an on-prem standpoint.
You have administrators
and architects
looking at taking workloads that
can't easily move to the cloud
and modernizing them.
And the path that we're seeing
here with a lot of customers
is they're taking
tools like Kubernetes
and figuring out how to run
them in on-prem environments
so that they can take
existing applications
and containerize them and
modernize in place so that they
can eventually move to
the public cloud at a pace
that they're comfortable with.
At the same time, there's
this very fast move
that's happening
where developers
are going off and containerizing
their applications
and running them in the cloud.
So as an organization,
you have to be
able to manage all these
various requirements that
are coming from your
developers, from your IT admins,
from your architects.
How do you do that?
What we're going to talk
about today is really
bridging together all these
various components, where
a developer can go from
source to image to container
to deployment environment,
and then a admin can
come along and specify
policy associated with how
these applications
run together--
who can talk to
what, who has access
to various components
within the architecture?
So all these various
roles would work together,
in terms of providing that
end-to-end state where you're
getting application agility,
you're getting faster time
to market, and at
the same time, IT
has control over
the environment.
And you're abstracting away
the underlying complexities--
the infrastructure--
as much as possible.
This is our goal.
So what if you can just
focus on innovating,
focus on writing code, and
then have the platform solve
all the gnarly problems
associated with connectivity,
associated with
policy enforcement,
and make it in such a way
that it's all API-driven
and you get the
best of both worlds?
What if you can do that?
So at Google, our open
hybrid cloud strategy
has really been focused
on three core tenants.
The first is Kubernetes.
Kubernetes has been
growing like crazy.
Since its introduction into
the open source world--
been four years now--
Kubernetes has seen
dramatic growth
and is now the de
facto orchestrator
for containers on the market.
And what Kubernetes
allows you to do
is build services and run
services and deploy services
very quickly in a
continuous fashion.
It makes it more predictable to
make changes to applications.
And it gives you the ability
now to run these services
in environments that
are heterogeneous
in nature, whether it's on one
cloud, on different clouds,
on-premise, without having
to rewrite your code.
That's the beauty of Kubernetes.
Then there's another component
called Open Service Broker.
Open Service Broker is really a
standard around consuming cloud
services where you can consume
these services pretty much
from anywhere.
And this is also an
open source project.
And then finally, Istio.
And I'm sure a lot of you
been hearing this week a lot
of information about Istio.
Istio is another
open source project
that was developed in
conjunction between Google,
Lyft, and IBM, where it solves
the challenges associated
with managing all these various
services that you've created
in heterogeneous environments.
How do you connect
these services together?
How do you ensure that
connectivity is secure
and get observability around
what these services are doing?
So if you were in the
keynote, you probably
saw a really cool demo around
how Istio can get metrics,
and then Stackdriver exposed
all dependency graphs,
in terms of how your services
are communicating together.
And Rohit is going to go really
deep into Istio in our talk
and give you really a
high level around what it
is, how it works.
And our demo will
actually be using Istio.
So the Cisco hybrid
platform for Google Cloud
is really about one very
important key tenet--
is the ability to write
once, deploy anywhere.
It's about being able to
build your application,
take your containers,
run them on Kubernetes,
and be able to run
those containers,
whether it's on Google
Kubernetes Engine or on-premise
on Cisco Container Platform.
The whole idea is, it's really
about agility and control.
You shouldn't have to
rewrite your application
when you move it from
environment to environment.
And this is the goal that we're
targeting together, in terms
of building this offering.
So why are we doing this?
The key here is, "hybrid" has
really become an overused term.
A lot of times when
people think about hybrid,
they think about a
single application that
spans multiple environments.
As a matter of fact,
that's a small portion
of the hybrid use cases
that exist out there today.
Many cases, hybrid is about
managing different applications
in different environments
in a consistent fashion.
So as people adopt
a hybrid strategy,
they run into big challenges.
First is connectivity.
How do you connect
from on-premise
to the public cloud
in a secure fashion,
in a fashion where you
have control around it,
and you can enforce policy
around who has access to what?
How do you spin up these
Kubernetes environments
anywhere and do it
in such a way that's
consistent with the
experience that you
have running in the cloud?
How do you manage these
Kubernetes environments,
again, consistently,
where you're
writing your application once
and deploying them anywhere?
And then support-- who's
going to support this?
You want a single support
arm that will support
your entire hybrid deployment.
That's the key.
And this is what Cisco
brings to the table
in our joint hybrid offering.
These are very hard
problems to solve.
And Google and Cisco
partner together
to bring really the
best of both worlds,
in terms of what both
companies bring to the table.
From a Google standpoint,
we bring Kubernetes.
We bring a lot of
the innovations
that we put forward, from
an open source standpoint,
around Kubernetes and Istio
and the work that we've
done around Google
Kubernetes Engine.
We also bring a set
of services that we've
developed around application
connectivity and all
these various components.
So together, we're bringing the
best of what both companies do
and offering it in
such a way where
it's turnkey and consumable
and supported consistently
across your hybrid environment.
And that's our goal.
So some of the use cases
that we're enabling--
and we'll be talking
in greater detail,
especially around
the third use case.
But the first few case is, how
do I connect from public cloud
to a system that's
sitting on-premise that
can't move to the public cloud?
Think of a legacy system or
some non-REST-based interface
that isn't modernized.
How do I do that?
This is the first use
case that we've enabled.
The second is
really about, how do
I consume cloud services from
on-prem, from Kubernetes,
in such a way that's consistent
across my environment?
Maybe I'd like to consume
from Google Cloud.
Maybe I want to consume
from other clouds.
But I want to consume
these services using
a consistent interface.
And then the third use case is
really around hybrid CI/CD--
Continuous Integration
Development--
where I'd like to be able to
write my application, perhaps,
for the public cloud,
but then move it
around different
environments without having
to rewrite my application.
Maybe I want to do
canary in public cloud,
and then trickle requests,
and then eventually push it
into production, or
blue-green tests and things
of that nature--
blue-green deployments.
That's really
about the third use
case-- the CI/CD deployments.
So for the first
use case, the idea
here is we want to
enable our customers
to be able to innovate
and build applications
in the public cloud.
But then these
applications should easily
be able to connect with systems
that are sitting in your data
centers.
And we do that by
leveraging Google Apigee.
And Google Apigee
is an API gateway
that really takes interfaces
that are non-modern,
non-REST interfaces, and it's a
layer that sits in front of it
and makes these
interfaces consumable
by modern applications.
So think of a use
case where you've
got a system that's storing
customer data that can't
move into the public cloud.
Maybe you're in a
regulated industry
where the data can't
move country boundaries
or things of that nature.
And then you want to
build a mobile app that
needs to really scale for
performance standpoint.
And you build that mobile
app in the public cloud.
Now that mobile app can handle
all the various requests that
are coming in, from a
front-end standpoint,
and scale efficiently,
but then can communicate
with these legacy systems
that are sitting in your data
center via the Apigee gateway.
That's the first use case.
And the key here is, the work
that we're doing with Cisco
is really about
pulling together--
they're called approved
reference architectures
that give you these capabilities
in a deployment model
so that you're not
having to install
all the various
components separately.
You want connectivity--
there's a Cisco CVD that
basically addresses
this use case
and gives you this particular
architectural pattern.
The second use case is
about consuming Google Cloud
Services.
So in Google Cloud,
we have this service
called Open Service Broker.
And what Open
Service Broker does
is it gives you the ability
to consume Google Cloud
Services from outside of Google
Cloud in a consistent fashion
so that you don't have to worry
about the semantics associated
with things like
service accounts,
having to figure out how
to translate information
from on-prem to the
public cloud service.
Open Service Broker
basically leverages
a component within Kubernetes
called Service Catalog, which
initiates a session
with Open Service Broker
and then passes the tokens
that gives you the ability
now to communicate
with that cloud service
and consume it from
outside of Google Cloud.
So it abstracts away the
complexities around security,
around the various
semantics associated
with that consumption pattern.
And then the third
use case is really
about a hybrid CI/CD pattern.
So the idea here
is, suppose I have
a containerized application
running in production.
I've got a new
version coming out.
I can deploy that new
version in Google Cloud,
run some canary testing,
and then be able to-- once
I'm positive, from
a policy standpoint,
that things are
working properly--
I can now have that
trickle into production
and have a new version
that's running,
and no impact on
my user experience.
And this is what
Rohit is actually
going to do a demo
later on in our session
and show you how that all works.
And before I hand it over to
Rohit to talk about the Cisco
components, let me
just spend a bit
of time talking about
Google Kubernetes Engine.
So I'm sure some of you
have been in sessions
and watched the Kubernetes
Engine pitch and so forth.
But I want to highlight
just a few things.
So Google Kubernetes Engine
has been a GA product now
for three years.
It is a managed
Kubernetes service that
runs on Google Cloud Platform.
It is 100% upstream Kubernetes.
This is not two versions behind.
Whenever there's a new
version of Kubernetes,
which is every three months,
Google Kubernetes Engine
supports that new version
within a couple of weeks.
Within a Kubernetes cluster,
there's usually a master,
and there is worker nodes.
With Kubernetes Engine,
Google manages the master.
We give you the ability
to auto-upgrade.
Any time there's a new
version, we'll notify you.
We will also auto-upgrade
your nodes, again,
through notification.
It's really up to you
to tell us how you want
those upgrades to take place.
We have an SRE team sitting
at Google that manages
the health of that cluster.
Anything happens, we fix it.
We ensure your applications
are running, are healthy.
It is integrated with the
underlying Google Cloud
auto-scaler.
So you're not only getting
container auto-scaling,
but you're getting
underlying node auto-scaling.
So you can define thresholds
and integrate with Stackdriver
for logging and monitoring.
Its built on top of
Google's network,
so it's a global network.
You can have clusters running
in different regions that
can talk to each other.
And from a compliance
standpoint,
it is certified across all the
various regulatory compliance--
HIPAA, PCI, and so forth.
And again, I just want
to stress that this
is upstream Kubernetes
and 100% compatible,
which means that when you
build applications on GKE,
those applications
can easily run
on Kubernetes' implementations
outside Google Cloud as well.
So with that said, I'll
hand it over to Rohit
to talk about Cisco
Container Platform.
ROHIT AGARWALLA: Thanks, Allan.
So as Allan mentioned,
Google Kubernetes Engine
is kind of a great
place for you to get
a cloud-managed
Kubernetes environment.
But from Cisco's perspective,
and overall as the partnership
with Google, what we have
been hearing from customers
is they also want to start on
the on-prem side, as described
in the third use case, where
you want to maybe start
in the public
cloud, but also want
to deploy it on-prem as
you move into production
or you have multiple edge
locations on which you want
to deploy your Kubernetes apps.
So we wanted to
essentially make sure
that we give you a
certified Kubernetes
platform available
on the on-prem that
integrates with
the infrastructure
that you have on
the on-prem side.
And we talk about
the infrastructure,
because our customers--
as our IT administrators,
the CIOs--
they have invested in
their infrastructure
over multiple years.
And as the transition
to the cloud happens,
they want to make sure that
that investment continues
to pay off as the transition
the cloud is happening.
So giving you a
production-ready, turnkey
container platform on
the on-premise side
helps to actually get benefit
out of your infrastructure
investments as well.
And as we go through
the presentation,
you will see how this integrates
with Cisco's infrastructure
specifically.
So as you can see on the
first and foremost point,
this is a fully 100%
upstream Kubernetes.
In fact, this is
certified platform.
We ran a bunch of CNCF tests
to make sure it's compatible.
It is hybrid cloud optimized
from a Google perspective.
So over the last
year, as we announced
the partnership back in October,
Cisco's Kubernetes engineering
team has been working very
closely with Google Kubernetes
Engine team to ensure some of
the configs and other things
that are needed on a
consistent environment
of the on-prem side,
we support that
as part of the deployment-- so
things like operating system
where we start with Ubuntu
in a very similar way in both
these environments.
Again, one of the things that
was mentioned earlier today
in the keynote by
[? AL ?] and Kip Compton
was around how Cisco
Container Platform
is the first and only
GKE-certified platform
and consistent with GKE
running on the on-prem side.
Third, from an
integration perspective,
we extend not just beyond
networking and storage,
but also from a cloud management
and analytics perspective,
we have all of
the Cisco products
that integrate to give you
a comprehensive multi-cloud
capability around the
Kubernetes environment
that's running on
the on-prem side.
And then finally, from
a flexible deployment
perspective, we
understand on the on-prem,
you have investments into
virtual machines where you're
deploying your
existing workloads
either on virtual machines
or bare-metal servers.
So we are giving
you the flexibility
to first spin up these
Kubernetes clusters
within virtual machines.
But in the future,
we'll also support
bare-metal infrastructure
where we'll give you
all the automation that's
needed under the hood
to bring up a full
infrastructure that
is ready for deploying all of
these Kubernetes [INAUDIBLE]
on top of that.
In addition to this,
again, Cisco's networking
infrastructure, from
an SDN perspective,
we integrate with that as well.
And we'll get into those
details just in a minute.
So the first
integration that I want
to talk about, from an
infrastructure perspective,
is with HyperFlex platform.
Our HyperFlex platform
is essentially
a hyper-converged
infrastructure that
combines compute and storage
within an on-prem environment.
And again, I'll be providing
you with a built-in iS platform.
So for our virtual machines, you
are getting the data management
capabilities in terms of
replication, as well as HA,
on the on-prem side.
But with the Kubernetes and
the Cisco Container Platform
integration, we wanted
to extend that support
to pods and Kubernetes
environment as well.
And so the way we
have done that is
we have developed a FlexVolume
driver that essentially gives
you the persistent volume
support for pods or containers
that are running within
a Kubernetes environment.
And the good part
is that this is,
as a turnkey configuration,
as an administrator
on the on-prem side, deploys
a Kubernetes cluster that
can pick and choose
the storage driver
that they want to enable
for the persistent volume.
So in case of pods move
from one node to the other
or your virtual machines move
from one node to the other,
your persistent volume
continues to be there,
because we chunk the data as
we write them into the disk,
using the software that
is running from a storage
perspective to chunk
across the multiple nodes,
as well as create
the replication
in case of node failures.
So all of those data
management capabilities
that you have with virtual
machines on HyperFlex,
you get with containers
that are running
within Kubernetes as part of
the Cisco Container Platform.
From a networking perspective,
Cisco's Application Centric
Infrastructure--
ACI-- that's our SDN controller.
And it essentially provides
you with network connection
as part of the SDN fabric, as
well as policy implementation,
using our Application Policy
Infrastructure Controller
called APIC.
And what we have done here is
we have created a Kubernetes CNI
driver, or Container
Networking Interface driver,
that essentially gives you
both Kubernetes network
connectivity, as well as
Kubernetes network policy
implementation within
the ACI fabric.
So imagine having an
on-prem environment
where the ACI is
in fabric, where
you have bare-metal
infrastructure
of virtual machines, as well
as now containers running
with Cisco Container Platform.
You can essentially
have the same fabric
within your on-prem environment
to give connectivity and apply
policies in a very
consistent way.
And we scale in a way so
that the fabric is actually
taking care of all the
network connectivity,
as well as implementing quality,
rather than doing everything
on the host and overloading our
hosts with those constructs.
The third integration
piece that we
have done as part of the
partnership and integration
is from a multi-cloud
application management
perspective.
Cisco Cloud Center essentially
supported deployment
of virtual machines,
and also talking
to other cloud services, and
defining a governance policy
in terms of what administrators
and what developers
can access to and what ports,
for example, can be opened up.
But we've also added the
support for Kubernetes.
So essentially, you can
define a YAML definition
or give a YAML definition
in Cloud Center and point
to a Kubernetes API, whether
that's running on top of CCP
or running within GKE, and have
a very consistent experience
in terms of deploying this
across the multiple cloud
environments.
Again, with the Cloud
Center UI, you also
get the capabilities to
embed some of the agents,
such as [INAUDIBLE] agent,
which we recently announced
Kubernetes support as well.
And so it gives you
a turnkey experience
of not just deploying
the application,
but also embedding agents
from an application monitoring
and visibility
perspective as well.
Now keep in mind, all of
these three integrations
I have talked about
from a use case
three perspective, which
is, we are giving you
a very consistent environment
across GKE, as well as on-prem.
And we've talked about
the HyperFlex integration,
which gives us storage.
We've talked about the ACI
integration, which gives us
the networking,
and Cloud Center,
which gives us the application
deployment construct.
The last piece that I want
to talk about this use case
and then dive into
the demo is Istio.
And I'm pretty sure you've heard
about Istio all over this week.
And so Istio is, again,
like an open-source project,
like Allan mentioned,
that was open source
by Google, IBM, and Lyft
about a year or so back.
And Cisco's got involved
into this open source project
as well.
And you'll see in the demo how
we are leveraging in use case
three, Istio--
how it plays a complete role
in defining your CI/CD platform
and deployments for
canary and A/B/n testing.
So very quick high level
overview of Istio--
first and foremost, it
gives you service discovery,
and not just for containers,
but also for other workloads.
Essentially by running that
sidecar proxy called Envoy,
which is what Istio
is supporting,
you can help to
dynamically discover
your services
across a multi-cloud
or a hybrid environment.
Then in terms of having
that type of proxy,
you can now offload a lot
of the functionality that
is very common to
your applications
into your sidecar proxy.
And this could be things like
circuit breaking, failure
recovery, load balancing.
So things that have been
traditionally done specifically
in the application
or by appliances
in a central location, now you
can have a distributed model
of implementing all of these
logic within that sidecar
proxy.
But Istio gives you
that control plane
to define how those
things should behave.
Now since that sidecar proxy
is in the path of deployment
or your traffic, you can now
also get all the [INAUDIBLE]
observability between
your services.
So that gives you
information about,
what is the communication graph
between different services?
What is the latency?
So you can get all of
those, in terms of a GKE
and a Cisco Container
Platform deployment, that
how are these
microservices or container
workloads communicating?
And what is the
latency between them?
And of course, security is
a very important aspect,
because as we see
workloads moving out
of the on-prem environment,
outside the firewall,
into the public cloud,
you want to make sure
that there is security not just
at the infrastructure level,
but also from a
networking perspective.
So you can create VPN tunnels.
But at the HTTP
level, you need things
like MTLS or mutual security--
TLS security-- that ensures
that only the right services are
talking to the other
services that are deployed
outside your environment.
So Istio, with its
sidecar proxy model,
gives you all of
those capabilities
in a hybrid environment.
And as part of our use case
three, we provide that.
This is a very quick,
high-level architecture diagram
of how Istio is deployed.
You can see the control
plane has three components.
It has the Istio Pilot, which
is responsible for essentially
pushing down and doing
the service discovery
and pushing down
the routing rules.
Mixer is essentially
ingesting all the data
from the sidecar to give you the
observability and the service
graph and how communications
are happening in the [INAUDIBLE]
enforcement between
the different services.
And finally, Citadel,
which is essentially
the service that's
providing MTLS
between various services
that are running
as part of your service mesh.
So all of these components
talk to essentially Envoy,
which is deployed within
each of your application
or microservice.
And Envoy exposes API through
which it still communicates
and enforces the policies.
And that's what we'll
see in the demo.
So specifically for
the hybrid use case
three, one of the features
that we have actually
pushed into the
community, and it's
going to be available
as part of Istio 1.0,
is the multi-cluster support.
And my demo is all around this.
So it's very important
to understand
what the multi-cluster
support is here.
So what multi-cluster
support does is,
you can have one single
Istio control plane.
So you're having,
essentially, a single instance
of Pilot, Mixer, and Citadel.
And that is essentially
pushing down policies
into multiple Envoys or
services that are running
in your hybrid environment.
Now you may have seen
things like Traffic Director
announcement
earlier from Google,
which is a manage service.
With this kind of a model, you
can deploy an Istio control
plane either on Google
Kubernetes Engine,
or you could deploy it on-prem.
So it gives you the flexibility
to maintain and manage
your Kubernetes control plane,
as well as the Istio control
plane, within your
own environment.
And so that's a key piece.
So let's look at
the demo topology
that we're going to show.
This is the Booksinfo app--
again, available
on the Istio site.
We've got a microservices
deployment made up
of four different microservices,
our product page, which
is the main entry page.
And it talks to the Reviews app.
It talks to Detail.
And Reviews talks to Ratings.
So Reviews is essentially
getting Ratings information
from the Rating service.
Now one thing to
note here is I've
got three versions of Reviews.
So Reviews 1 gives me no stars.
Reviews 1 gives me black stars.
And Reviews 3
gives me red stars.
So in our demo, what
we'd be doing essentially
is, we'll start with Reviews
v1 and v2 deployed on GKE.
And then we'll spin up
Reviews v3 on the on-prem side
as a new service
and see how traffic
is getting load-balanced.
So this is our
deployment architecture.
From the GKE side, we'll
have all the services
except Reviews v3 running.
Again, this could also be a
completely flip deployment,
where you could have all of
these things running on Cisco
Container Platform as well.
But for this demo,
we'll have everything
running, except for Reviews v3,
on Google Kubernetes engine.
And then we'll spin
up Reviews v3 on CCP,
or Cisco Container
Platform-based Kubernetes.
One important thing
to note here is
the pod IP addresses have
completely different ranges.
So how do you actually ensure
that you are discovering
these services that are in
completely different subnets
across these two environments?
So that's where
some of the magic
that we have done,
in terms of enabling,
for example, the
Cloud Services router
1000v on Google
Cloud, that helps
you to create that VPN tunnel.
So there is already
a VPN tunnel set up.
There is already
Stealthwatch Cloud,
which is monitoring this
connection from a security
perspective.
And we'll talk about the
details about that integration
later as well.
But that's all set up as part
of this tunnel between these two
environments.
So as we see into
the demo, we'll
see essentially all of these
services that are running will
have a sidecar proxy within it.
And that essentially helps
to discover the services
across the GKE and the
on-prem environment.
So enough of this.
Let's switch into the
terminal here and actually see
this in action.
All right.
So this is my jump host.
And this is running,
essentially,
a virtual machine that is
running on Google Cloud.
And as part of that
VPC deployment,
I have got a VPN tunnel back
to my on-prem environment,
where I have got Cisco Container
Platform-based Kubernetes
deployment.
So here, let's first get
into the GKE deployment.
I will do cube caudal
context config, get context.
And you can see this is
essentially my GKE base
cluster.
We can go back here
into my browser
and see this is the cluster
that I'm essentially showing--
Cisco Live, it is running west.
10.40 is the pod IP range, as
I had shown in the picture.
And let's see, what are
the different pods that
are running?
So I'm going to
just do Get Pods.
This essentially
should return me,
from my app perspective
in the default
namespace, all the
services that I had shown,
except for Reviews v3.
So everything is running on top
of my Google Kubernetes Engine
deployment.
Let's look at the services
that are running here.
So essentially, it
will give me, again,
in the default namespace,
against those pods,
the right services
that are running.
Now let's look at actually the
services in my Istio system
namespace.
So like I had mentioned, you
have a complete control plane
of Istio that is running.
And in this case, it's all
deployed in Google Kubernetes
Engine.
So I've got all
of these services
that you see here that
are running on the Google
Kubernetes Engine.
One thing to note here is
the Ingress Gateway Service.
This is my entry point
into my service mash.
And it has a load balancer type.
You may be familiar with
this from a Kubernetes
implementation point of view.
And it has got an external
IP assigned to it.
And so I am going to essentially
be accessing my application
using this external IP.
So this is my entry point
that takes the traffic,
and then goes
through the sidecar
proxy to all the services that
are running within the service
mash.
So just to validate this,
let's-- remember this IP.
It is 215-- go back
to our application
and see the front end page.
And you can see here it's 215.
I don't know, back,
if you can see that.
But trust me, it's 215.
And we'll just refresh this.
And as I'm doing
refresh, you can see,
I'm seeing no stars
and black stars.
So essentially, that
is Reviews v1 and v2
getting load balanced
as I am sending requests
to my product page across
into the service mesh.
So now let's go back
here into my terminal.
And what we'll do is we'll
go to the on-prem site.
So I just switched context here.
I'm going to issue
the same command here.
And I can show you, this
is now a different context
which is basically running
a Cisco Container Platform
provision Kubernetes cluster
on top of my Cisco HyperFlex
infrastructure with ACI.
So those are the storage drivers
and the networking plug-in
that have been enabled.
What I'm going to do here
[INAUDIBLE] similar commands
here.
So I'm going to
first do, get pods.
And here, what we
should see essentially
is a bunch of Cisco
Container Platform add-ons
that we are enabling
on the on-prem side,
but no Reviews v3.
So that is the part that
I'm going to spin up--
a Reviews v3 app here--
and see how that works.
So let's look at the
Reviews v3 app definition.
So this is my Reviews v3 app.
Ratings, I have only got
a service definition,
because my Reviews
talks to Ratings,
but I don't have any pods
going to be running on-prem.
But I've got a
Reviews definition.
And I've got a deployment
that says Reviews v3.
And as part of that,
I'm also giving
a sidecar proxy that I'm
injecting, which is Envoy,
as part of a deployment.
So let's go ahead and
do a kubectl create
minus F remote [INAUDIBLE].
Again, because of the CRDs that
are supported within Kubernets,
which is Custom Resource
Definitions, the definition
of my Remote app, which
I just showed you,
with the extensions of
enabling an Envoy or a sidecar
proxy in my app, Kubernetes,
with the CRD support,
can understand it.
So we'll go ahead
and deploy this.
It just got deployed.
We'll give it a couple of
seconds for it to come up.
As it comes up, what is
happening in the background
is essentially this service,
with the sidecar proxy
is getting registered
with my Istio control
plane that is running on
Google Kubernetes Engine.
And as that gets registered,
the control plane essentially
gets to know that if
there is a request that
is going to Reviews, I can send
it across to a new version that
has just come up.
So let's go back
to our app here.
And I'm going to start
refreshing here again.
And what are you seeing
are red stars come up.
And essentially, this tells
me that with black stars,
that I am now starting
to load balance
across multiple versions
of my Reviews app
that was running across on-prem,
as well as GKE environment.
So again, you can see I'm
continuously just refreshing
it.
And I'm seeing black
stars and red stars.
And there should be
no stars as well.
There you go.
So in a random load balancing
fashion, this is happening.
Traditionally, or
previously, if you
had to do this in
your environment,
across a public cloud and
an on-prem environment,
you would have probably
a load balancer.
And that load balancer,
you would have a VIP.
And that VIP
somehow needs to get
configured with a new back
end of your service version
that comes up.
And there would have been new
manual configuration that you
would have to push in into
the load balance [INAUDIBLE]----
all of that.
But as you can see in this
demo, as your devleopers spun up
a new version of an application,
your operations team,
with this Istio
control plane, can now
actually observe that a
new version has come up
and assign rules, in
order to send the traffic
to these new versions
in a very dynamic
and a very consistent way.
So that's one
aspect of the demo.
Now let's say your
developer says,
Reviews 3 is actually the best
version that I've seen so far,
and I want all of
my client traffic
that's coming from
anywhere in the world
to be now sent to Reviews v3.
So how do I actually apply this
policy into my service mesh
without disrupting the
traffic to all other versions,
and maybe without even taking
down my Reviews v1 and v2?
So before that, what
I'm going to do is I'm
going to switch back
into my GKE environment,
because that's where my Istio
control plane is running.
And I'm going to look
into a definition here
of a policy which is a virtual
service construct in Istio.
And this essentially
is a policy definition
that says that if any traffic
to a destination called Reviews,
I need to send it to v3.
So Istio understands this.
It can push down into
the Envoy sidecar
proxy that's running
in my service mesh
across these two environments.
And then hopefully, as we try to
again refresh our product page
entry, it will send all
the traffic to Reviews v3.
So let's go ahead and do
that again with a kubectl
create command here
and clear that policy.
So I just created that
virtual service policy.
And it's implementing that into
all the Envoy sidecars that are
running within my deployment.
And I'm going to start
refreshing here again.
And what do you see here
now as I refresh this?
Only red stars
are getting shown.
I'm not seeing any black stars.
I'm not seeing any no stars,
which essentially is telling me
that that policy just got
applied into my service mesh,
and my developer gave
thumbs up to this version,
and my operator is
now able to monitor
how my service is
getting communicated
between the different
microservices.
Additionally, you can
see here a full graph
of all the communication that
is happening within my service
deployment.
So Envoy, from an
observability point of view,
gives you this right
out of the box--
that these are the
different services that
are part of the service mesh
and the number of connections
and requests that are going
between these services.
Now let's say that
you actually wanted
to go back and do, again,
the random load balancing,
because you started to see
some service degradation.
In that case, you'd
essentially want
to go back here and
just delete this policy.
And hopefully, now
everything should come back
to what it was before, which
is the load balance across all
the three versions of Reviews.
So if we go back here and
start refreshing our app here,
and you can see
black stars start
to pop up, red stars, no stars.
So I'm able to roll back my
policy definitions, based
on how my services are
essentially performing
into my deployment, and
make those decisions quickly
and implement them very
quickly in a very consistent
environment across a
hybrid environment,
because typically, you would
do these things in a cloud
environment, using things like
security groups or firewalls
within those environments.
And in the on
prem-side, you will
have, again, similar devices.
But with the Istio and
service mesh model,
you essentially have a layer
between your LTL4 and L7
to apply these policies once
and apply them very consistently
across these multiple
environments.
So let's switch back
here to our slides.
That was essentially the demo.
So like I mentioned,
in this set-up,
there was networking also
going on in the back end,
from an LTL4 perspective,
as well as security.
And that is essentially cutting
across all of our three use
cases that we have.
So first and foremost was the
Stealthwatch Cloud integration
with Google Cloud or
Google VPC, specifically.
Essentially, our
Stealthwatch Cloud
is essentially a SaaS
product from Cisco
that enables you to monitor
the network connections going
into your VPC resources
in a cloud environment
and also your on-prem
review resources.
Here we have
integrated specifically
with VPC flow logs
in Google Cloud.
So you can ingest all the VPC
flow logs on the Google Cloud
into the Stealthwatch
Cloud service
to give you visibility
of things like,
what are the number of
network connections going
into your Kubernetes pods,
or to your virtual machines?
Similarly, on the on-prem
environment in Cisco Container
platform, we enable
the deployment
of Stealthwatch sensors, which
essentially puts all NetFlow
data into the SaaS
service that's
provided by Stealthwatch Cloud.
This service, again,
was available--
has been GA-ed in
March earlier this year
and is essentially
part of the solution.
The second integration
that was also
in the demo, running
in the background,
was Cloud Services
Router 1000v--
Cisco Cloud Services Router
1000v-- on Google Cloud.
Our CSR 1000v has been very
popular in other clouds.
And based on a lot of
the customer requests,
and as part of this
partnership, we
wanted to give a very
similar iOS on-prem
experience on Google
Cloud for our customers.
And that is what
CSR 1000v provides.
It gives you extended
capabilities,
not just from an IPSec
perspective, but also DMVPN
and [INAUDIBLE]
that you can apply
across multiple on-prem data
centers or campus and branches,
using the CSR running
on Google Cloud.
Again, this will be
part of the solution
and enables you to give that
pod-to-pod connectivity in case
if they're running
in different subnets.
So let's bring all
of this together.
So we've talked a lot
about three different use
cases, different components.
So how does all of
this come together?
So as you can see
on the on-prem side,
it's starting with
the infrastructure.
We have got HyperFlex.
We have got ACI from Cisco.
We have got the Cisco
Container Platform
that integrates with these.
We've got Service Catalog
that enables you to consume,
via Open Service Broker, all
the Google Cloud Services.
We've got Istio that
is running on-prem
or in Google Cloud to give
you the service mesh layer.
And then Apigee gives you,
on-prem, the capability
to expose your traditional
systems for things
that are running in
Google Kubernetes Engine.
And then finally, Cloud Center
that gives you the capability
to deploy these things
across multiple environments.
So this is our overall
architecture that
brings everything together.
This is going to be,
as Allan mentioned,
a Cisco Validated Design.
So all the components that
you see in this picture,
they will be available to
you as single products.
But with the joint
partnership, we
are going to be giving you
a validated design that
ensures that these are
working together to give you
the benefit of making them work
together, as well as supported
jointly by Cisco and Google.
So things like, when you
need Kubernetes support,
when you need
Istio support, they
will be jointly supported
by Cisco and Google
as part of this entire
partnership and solution.
Now one of the things
that we have done here
over the last few months as we
have announced this partnership
are the various milestones
that you see in this picture.
So Cisco joined the Istio
community back in July 2017.
The feature that I
just showed you was,
well, pushed through
Cisco, working very closely
with Google engineers.
We announced the hybrid cloud
partnership back in October
at the Cisco's Partner Summit.
In November, we announced
the multi-cloud portfolio,
in which hybrid cloud
is also part of it.
January, in Cisco
Live Barcelona,
we announced the Cisco
Container Platform, and then
Stealthwatch Cloud and the
CloudCenter app [INAUDIBLE]
Kubernetes support followed on.
At this conference, we
announced another thing,
was the Cisco and Google
Cloud developer challenge.
So this is a challenge
that essentially leverages
a lot of the
technology components
that we have talked
about so far--
so things like Cisco Container
Platform, Google Kubernetes
Engine, Istio.
And there are
multiple prizes that
are to be awarded as
part of this challenge.
We have opened up
registration for it.
Here's the URL for it
that you can check it out.
But the key thing
to remember here
is that we see not only those
three use cases as the starting
point, but opening
up the technology
components to our customers,
to our developers and partners
to innovate around
using these use case.
So at the end, closing this--
and we'll open up for questions
here--
is that we want to
essentially give you
a platform that is
supported by Cisco
that enables you to move to the
public cloud at your own pace.
You can innovate and
move to modernization,
as well as leverage
open source components
in your environment that
is supported jointly
by Cisco and Google.
[MUSIC PLAYING]